-Our first guest tonight
is a producer
and Emmy Award-winning actor
you know from shows such as
"This Is Us"
and "American Crime Story"
and films like "Waves"
and "Black Panther."
He just received his first
Academy Award nomination
for his role as Cliff
in "American Fiction,"
which is in theaters now.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend, Sterling K. Brown,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I mean. I mean.
Sterling!
-What's up, buddy?
-I have grown accustomed
to having you come on
and introducing you
as an Emmy Award-winning actor.
-Sure.
-But Academy Award-nominated,
it's a nice ring to it.
-It's not terrible.
-It's not -- It's pretty good.
-I dig it, it's pretty cool.
-It's pretty good.
We were talking backstage.
-Yeah.
-It's very exciting.
When you get nominated
for one of these awards,
there's a ton of events.
-Yeah.
-Not just the press tour,
but also, you get to hang out
with the other nominees,
and it's a pretty good bunch.
-This is very true.
I got a chance to hang out --
She wasn't nominated this year
for an Academy Award,
but she was nominated
for an Emmy.
Uh, Meryl Streep.
-Yes.
-We were at this --
Yeah, that's the right --
That's the right thing.
Because if you know anything
about me, I'm a big Streep fan.
-Yeah.
-And she saw "American Fiction,"
and she told me how much
she enjoyed my work.
And she kissed me.
-Yeah.
-She kissed me, like,
right there.
And my wife saw it,
so it's legit, like,
it's not a thing.
-Yeah.
-But it's also a thing.
-Does it bother you at all?
Does it bother you at all,
knowing that
if she hadn't seen it
and was just lying to you,
you wouldn't be able to tell,
because she's so good?
-No. As long as
I wound up with the kiss,
that's all I really care about.
-The kiss was real.
-That's it, that's it.
-Have you tried to get any
friends and family
to start referring to you
as
"the Academy Award-nominated?"
-Not just yet.
-Yeah.
-My son --
So I got nominated
for a few things before.
I got nominated
for a SAG Award,
what have you,
and my son loves to sort of
take the crap out of me, right?
-Yeah.
-And he's like, what is this?
-Like, how old? What do we got?
-He's 12.
-Yeah. That's the take a crap.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's like, what's that,
the Stupid Ass Gorilla award?
That's like SAG.
-Yep.
-Sort of thing.
-SAG,
you got to be honest,
I was asking for it.
-There you go, there you go.
So I was like, yeah, whatever.
So then I showed him,
I was like, hey,
you know, I got nominated
for an Oscar, you know?
And he goes, "Oh, yeah,
is that what? Uh..."
-Yeah, too many letters.
-And then he was like...
Congrats, dad.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
-It's cool, it's cool.
-You shared this
on social media.
You had a real, you know --
At the end of the day,
yes, you're an actor,
but based on how you found
out, you are a dad first.
And I found that very endearing
because everybody always said,
how did you find out?
And the way you found out
is more in line with my life
as a dad than --
certainly my life --
-Because you have younger --
You're seven, five, two.
I fell asleep
in the bedroom with him.
I had my phone on.
The phone died.
I woke up in the middle
of the night, got off the floor,
went to my bed with my wife,
which is where
I'm supposed to sleep.
I charged my phone.
I wake up in the morning,
I go start feeding
them breakfast.
I go pick up the phone
that's now 126 text messages.
And I'm like, why am I -- 120 --
It's 7 in the morning!
Because I got nominated
for an Academy Award.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, based on that,
like, going into -- you know,
when you went to bed that night,
what was your --
what was your thinking?
I mean, obviously some people
had said this was possible.
But...
-Some said it was possible.
I did not think it was.
-Okay.
-I thought that there was
going to be other people
who were going to be nominated,
and I would have been more
than happy to congratulate them
and wish them well.
A young man from "The Holdovers"
and from "May/December"
and for other things.
Right?
Uh, Willem Dafoe, etc...
So I was like, you know what?
If it happens, it happens.
If it doesn't, it doesn't.
I was not going to sweat it
one way or the other.
I was pleasantly surprised.
-It's a very nice thing
to be --
-Seth, I still -- I feel like
a baby in this industry,
and when I see all the people
who I got nominated along with,
I'm just, like, honored
to be a part of the group.
-It is a very nice thing,
and it's very well deserved.
You're wonderful in the film.
You're a wife is also an actor.
-She is.
-And she's been nominated for
some things in the past as well.
And I was going to ask about
who's your plus one
at the Academy Awards.
I assumed it would be her.
-So this is -- Okay.
My wife was the first person
ever nominated for something
in our couple.
She was a series regular
on "Boston Legal,"
and she got nominated
for best ensemble
for a Screen Actors
Guild Award.
Or, you know,
Stupid Ass Gorilla.
And I was like, oh man,
we get to go to the SAG Awards.
It's going to be so much fun.
We get to it.
And she's like, "Actually,
Sterling,
like, I think I should
probably take my manager
because there's a good
networking opportunity for me."
And I was like, oh, cool,
cool, cool, I got it.
No problem. That's fine.
Don't worry about it.
So then things ,like,
you know,
a few years later start
happening for your boy.
And she's like, "Oh, my God,
we get to go to the Emmys?"
And I was like, we?
I don't --
[ Laughter ]
-This is a very, a very useful
lesson about a married couple.
And I should say,
you and your wife
obviously have
a nice perspective on this,
and you're also starting
a podcast together.
-We are.
-And this is launching
on Valentine's Day.
-Launching on Valentine's Day.
It's called
"We Don't Always Agree,
with Ryan and Sterling."
We've been married for 18 years.
And you guys know, if you've
been together that long,
you don't always agree,
but you figure a way
to make it out,
and it's --
we had so much fun.
We're doing 12 episodes.
Hopefully, people
are enjoying them.
We'll do a season two.
-Now, I would ask, this --
is it -- when you talk to your
wife about how you don't agree.
-Yeah.
-I would imagine knowing
that other people
are going to hear it,
it makes it
the best versions of yourself.
Like if my wife --
-No.
-Oh, interesting.
Well, what I want
is full accountability,
because my wife will say crazy
things when we're by ourselves.
-Yes.
-I was like,
say that [bleep] right now.
-Yeah.
-So that everybody
can hear it,
and then
we'll find out who's crazy.
-I mean, when -- I couldn't
agree with you more.
When my wife and I are fighting,
the amount I want to be like,
"You know what?
Let's do it as a podcast."
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Let's take it
out in the streets.
-Let's take it out
in the streets.
-Yeah, we'll get some sponsors.
-There you go.
Um, I have a lot more
to ask you.
Will you stick around?
You guys, that's Sterling.
More after this.